[Music]
by way of preface i shall inform the
reader that my intention is to give a
succinct account
of some of my adventures dangers and
sufferings during my several campaigns
in the revolutionary army
should the reader chance to ask himself
this question how could any man of
common sense ever spend his precious
time in writing such a
rhapsody of nonsense i would inform him
that
every private soldier in an army thinks
his particular service is
as essential as the services of the most
influential general
and why not what could officers do
without
such men nothing at all alexander
could never have conquered the world
without private soldiers
[Music]
i remember the stir in the country
occasion by the stamp act
but i was so young that i did not
understand the meaning of it i
likewise remember the disturbances that
followed the repeal of the stamp act
until the destruction of the tea at
boston and elsewhere
i was then 13 or 14 years old
and began to understand something of the
works going on
i used about this time to inquire a
great deal about the french war
as it was called which had not been long
ended my grandsire would talk to me then
while working in the fields
i thought then nothing should induce me
to get caught up in the toils of an army
i am well so i'll keep was my motto then
and it would have been well for me if i
had retained it
time passed smoothly on with me till the
year 1774
arrived the smell of war began to be
pretty strong but i was determined to
have no hand in it
what venture my carcass where bullets
fly
that will never do for me during the
winter of 1775 to 76
by hearing the conversation and disputes
of the good old farmer politicians of
the times
i collected pretty correct ideas of the
contest between this country
and the mother country as it was then
called i thought i was as warm a patriot
as the best of them
the war was waged we had joined issue
and it would not do to put the hand to
the plow and look back
i felt more anxious than ever if
possible
to be called a defender of my country
[Music]
well enlisting orders were out i used
frequently to go to the rendezvous where
i saw many of my young associates enlist
had repeated banterings to engage with
them but still when it came to
case in hand i had my misgivings
if i once undertake thought i i must
stick to it
there would be no receding so seating
myself at the table
enlisting orders were immediately
presented to me i took up the pen
loaded it with the fatal charge made
several mimic imitations of running my
name but took a special care not to
touch the paper with the pen
until an unlucky white who was leaning
over my shoulder
gave my hand a stroke which caused the
pen to make a woeful scratch on the
paper
oh he has enlisted said he he has made
his mark he is fast enough now
well thought i i might as well go
through the business now as not
so i wrote my name fairly upon the
indentures
and now i was a soldier
in name at least if not in practice this
video is sponsored by magellan tv
the documentary streaming service so
quick update from coco she's now in
charge of finding all the sources for
voices of the past
unfortunately she speaks spanish and
these are english translations
and she's a cat
so if you guys have any suggestions
please leave a comment and a great place
to be inspired is magellan tv
and our recommendation this week is
yellowstone one of the many new
documentaries recently added to the
service
partnered with america from above these
two documentaries really give you a
sense of the vastness
and beauty of american nature magellan
is essentially a netflix for
documentaries with the largest range of
history stuff
anywhere and over 3 000 documentaries
with new ones being added
all the time so click on the link in the
description for an exclusive
month-long free trial for voices of the
past viewers
thanks
i had obtained my heart's desire it was
now my business to prove myself equal
to my profession well to be short i went
with several others of the company on
board a sloop
bound to new york had a pleasant though
projected passage
passed through the strait called hell
gate arrived at
new york marched up into the city and
joined the rest of the regiment
soon after my arrival in new york a
44-gun ship
the phoenix and a small frigate the rose
i think
came down the north or hudson river and
passed the city in fine style
amidst a cannonade from all our
fortifications in and near the city
i went into what was then called the
grand battery where i had a complete
view of the whole affair
here i first heard the muttering of a
cannon shot
but they did not disturb my feelings so
much as i apprehended they would before
i heard them
i rather thought the sound was musical
or at least grand i heard enough of them
afterwards
to form what ideas i pleased of them
i remained in new york two or three
months when sometime in the latter part
of the month of august
the regiment was ordered to long island
the british having landed in force
although this was not unexpected to me
yet it gave me a rather
disagreeable feeling as i was pretty
well assured i should have to snuff a
little gunpowder
however i kept my concentrations to
myself went to my quarters
packed up my clothes and got myself in
readiness for the expedition
as soon as possible i then went to the
top of the house
where i had a full view of that part of
the island i distinctly saw the smoke of
the field artillery
the horrors of battle and presented
themselves to my mind in all their
hideousness
i must come to it now thought i well
i will endeavor to do my duty as well as
i am able
we quickly embarked on board the boats
as each boat started three cheers were
given by those on board
which was returned by the numerous
spectators who thronged to the wharves
although it was with most of them
perhaps nothing more than ceremony
[Music]
we soon landed at brooklyn upon the
island
and marched up the ascent from the ferry
to the plain we now began to meet with
wounded men another side i was
unacquainted with
some with broken arms some with broken
legs and some with broken heads
the side of those a little daunted me
and made me think of home but the sight
and thought
vanished together we pressed forward
towards a creek
where a large party of americans and
british were engaged
by the time he arrived the enemy had
driven our men into the creek
where such as could swim got across
those that could not swim and could not
procure anything to buoy them up
sunk
our regiment then lay on the ground we
then occupied the following night
the next day in the afternoon we had a
considerable tight scratch
with about an equal number of the
british which began unexpectedly
a few of our men went over the creek
upon business that usually employed us
that is
in search of something to eat there was
a field of indian corn at a short
distance from the creek
the men purposed to get some of the corn
or anything that was eatable
when they got up with the haycocks they
were fired upon by an equal number of
the british from the cornfield
our people took to the hay and the
others to the fence where they exchanged
the number of shots at each other
neither side inclining to give back a
number say
40 or 50 more of our men went over and
drove the british from the fence
they were by this time reinforced in
their turn and drove us back
the two parties kept us alternately
reinforcing until we had most of our
regiment in the action
the english were soon routed from the
place but we dared not to follow them
for fear of falling into some snare as
the whole british army
was in the vicinity of us
i do not recollect that we had anyone
killed outright but we had several
severely wounded and some i believe
mortally i never wish to do anyone an
injury
through malice in my life nor did i do
anyone
an intentional injury when i was in the
army unless it was when sheer necessity
drove me to it
and my conscience bears me witness that
innumerable times i have suffered
rather than take from anyone what
belonged of right to them
even to satisfy the cravings of nature
and now who's coming on the famous kipps
bay affair
which has been criticized so much by the
historians of the revolution
i was there and will give a true
statement of all that i saw
during that day it was on a sabbath
morning the day in which the british
were always employed about their devilry
if possible i had stepped into an old
warehouse which stood close to me and
sat down upon a stool
the floor was strewn with papers which
had in some form or period been used in
the concerns of the house i was very
demurely
perusing these papers when all of a
sudden there came such a pearl of
thunder from the british shipping
that i thought my head would go with the
sound i made a frog's leap for the ditch
and lay as still as i possibly could and
began to consider
which part of my carcass was to go first
in retreating i had to cross a level
clear spot of ground
40 or 50 rods wide exposed to the whole
of the enemy's fire
and they gave it to us in prime order
the grape shot flew merrily
which served to quicken our emotions
when i had gotten a little out of the
reach of their combustibles i found
myself in company
with one who was a neighbor of mine one
at home we went into a house by the
highway
in which were two women and some small
children we asked the woman if they had
any spirits in the house
they placed a case bottle of rum upon
the table and bit us to help ourselves
each of us drank a glass and bidding
them goodbye we took ourselves to the
highway again
we had not been long on this road before
we saw another party
just ahead of us whom we knew to be
americans just as we overtook these we
were fired upon by a party of british
from a cornfield
and all was immediately in confusion
again i believe the enemy's party was
small but our people were all militia
and the demons of fear and disorder
seemed to take full possession of all
and everything on that day we had to
advance slowly for my comrade having
been
sometime unwell was now so overcome by
heat hunger and fatigue
that he became suddenly violently sick i
took his musket and endeavoured to
encourage him on
he was as i before observed a nine
neighbor of mine one at home and i was
loathe to leave him behind
although i was anxious to find the main
part of the regiment
we had proceeded but a short distance
however before we found our retreat cut
off by a party of the enemy
stretched across the island i
immediately quitted the roads and went
into the fields where there happened to
be a small spot of boggy land
covered with low bushes and weeds
into these iran and squatting down
concealed myself from their sight
several of the british came so near to
me i could see the buttons on their
clothes
they however soon withdrew and left the
coast clear for me again
i then came out of my convert and went
on but what i've become of my sick
comrade or the rest of my companions
i knew not
i still kept the sick man's musket i was
unwilling to leave it for
it was his own property i had indeed
enough to do to take care of my own
concerns it was exceeding hot weather
and i was faint having slept
very little on the preceding night nor
had i eaten a mouthful of rituals for
more than 24 hours
i waddled on as well and as fast as i
could and soon came up with a number of
men at a small brook
where they had stopped to drink and rest
themselves a few moments
just as i arrived a man had laid down to
drink at the brook
and as he did not rise very soon one of
the company observed
that he would kill himself with drinking
upon which
another touching him without his
appearing to notice it
said that he had already killed himself
which was the case
[Music]
i passed across the corner of one field
and threw a gap in a cross fence into
another
and here i found a number of men resting
under the trees
almost the first i saw was my sick
friend i was exceeding glad to find him
for i had but little hope of ever seeing
him again he was sitting near the fence
with his head between his knees
i tapped him upon the shoulder and asked
him to get up and go with me
no said he i must die here
i endeavored to argue the case with him
but all to no purpose he insisted upon
dying there
i told him he should not die there nor
anywhere else that day if i could help
it
and at length with more persuasion and
some force i succeeded in getting him up
on his feet again
and moving on there happened at this
time to be a considerable shower of rain
which weathers through to the skin being
very thinly clad
we however continue to move forward
although
more slowly after proceeding about half
a mile we came to a place where our
people had begun to make a stand
i and my comrades were stopped here a
sentinel being placed in the road to
prevent our going any further
i remonstrated with the officer who
detained us but i told him i had a sick
man with me who was wet and would die if
exposed all night to the damp cold air
hoping by this to move his compassion
but it would not do
well said he if he dies the country will
be rid of one
who can do it no good it was now almost
sundown
and the air quite chilly after the
shower i was really afraid my sick man
would die
there came to the sentinel i suppose an
old acquaintance of his
with a canteen containing some sort of
spirits
after drinking himself he gave it to the
sentinel who took a large pull upon it
they then fell into conversation and
kept my eyes upon them
and when i saw a chance of getting from
them i gave my companions a wink
and we passed by the sentinel without
him noticing us
at all we proceeded but had not gone far
when we came up with the regiment
resting themselves upon the cold ground
after the fatigues of the day
our company all appeared to rejoice to
see us thinking we were killed or
prisoners
i was sincerely glad to see them for i
was once more
among friends we were the last who came
up
all the others who were missing were
either killed or taken prisoners
and here ends the kip's bay affair which
caused at the time and has
since caused much ink shed anecdotes
jests
imprecations and sarcasms have been
multiplied and even the grave writers of
the revolution have said and written
more about it than it deserved
i could make some observations but it is
beyond my province
i had learned something of a soldier's
life enough i thought to keep me at home
for the future
indeed i was then fully determined to
rest easy with the knowledge i had
acquired in the affairs of the army
but the reader will find if he has
patience to follow me a little longer in
my details
that the ease of a winter spent at home
caused me
to alter my mind
[Music]
you